ازمه غناء ويجز ويكس طبعا هو يعني شاب
مصري ومغني راب معروف جدا وله شعبيه كبيره
واللي صار انه تم الاعلان عن مشاركته في
الحفله الختامي لمونديال كاس العالم في
قطر ولعت الدنيا تهاني وتبريكات انه شاب
مصري بدا من الصفر وراح يشارك فحدث عالمي
مهم وبيستنونا الناس كل اربعه سنوات وطلعت
اخبار انه النقابه قالت انه لازم ياخذ
تصريح من النقابه قبل ما يغني في كاس
العالم وهنا زعلوا الناس من النقابه وحتى
في مشاهير انتقدوا القرار الفيفا اصدرت
يوم السبت بيان عن جدول الحفل الختامي
اللي راح يستمر 15 دقيقه ووصفته انه راح
يكون حفل خالد في ذاكره 88000 متفرج داخل
استاذ والبيان عنوانه لتتاخر ولا تتاخروا
الحفل الختام قطر 20 20 22 يشعل حماسه
الجماهير في استاذ لوسيل وتم استعراض
الفقرات الغنائيه اللي راح تتضمن توليفه
موسيقيه من الاغاني الرسميه للبطوله
بيان الفيفا ما جاب اي سيره لمشاركه ولد
في الحفل الختامي وهذا الشيء يخلي الجدل
يكبر والتنبؤات تكثر لكن مدير اعماله عاصم
تاج امس طلع مع الزميل عمرو اديب من
برنامج الحكايه ونفى ونسف كل الروايات
السابقه واكد انه وجزر رح يشارك في حفل
الختامي او في انه خلال اخر مباراه يعني
عاصم تاج صاحب شركه تي ام تي ام ومدير
اعمال ويويز اهلا بك يا فندم
اهلا بك استاذ عمرو عامل ايه اخبارك ايه
الحمد لله انت الوحيد اللي ممكن بقى تقول
لنا اين سيكون ويجز وماذا سيحدث غدا
اللعيبه هتخش تقعد في اللوكر بتاعه
هيطلع على الناس في الملعب ويغني
[موسيقى]
وبعدين هيخش على الفصل الاعلان يعني هم
ماخرين حتى على التلفزيون
الاغنيه كامله وبعدين يكمله
الحفل النهائي لكاس العالم في قطر او زي
ما قال مدير اعماله انه بين الشوطين في
ستوري للمغني نفسه كان ناشرها من ساعتين
تقريبا على صفحته وبيظهر فيها متواجد فيه
ستاد لوسيل
طب ما انا عبر الهاتف من القاهره مصطفى
كامل نقيب المهن الموسيقيه في مصر اهلا
فيك معنا استاذ مصطفى انا حابه اتكلم معك
عن حمله الهجوم اللي تم شنها على النقاب
على
عقيل انه بسبب معارضتها لموضوع غناء اذا
تقدر توضح لي موقف النقابه من هذا الموضوع
اولا مساء الخير حضرتك اهلا وسهلا
موقف النقابه واضح وصريح واعلامه وتكرارا
بقى لي اربع ايام دلوقتي موقف النقابه انا
ومجلس اداره ولا باكلمك دلوقت من داخل
نقابه الموسيقيه مجتمع بمجلس الاداره
بالكامل
لاي انسان او فنان مصري يمثل مصر بالخارج
ده يبقى شرف كبير لينا بنقعد كل الدعم وكل
المحبه وكل التقدير وربنا يوفقه وربنا
يكرمه ده موقف مصطفى كامل الشخصي والنقيب
ومجلس اداره نقابه الموسيقيه كل ما طرح
عبر وسائل الاعلام المهارات وادخلت
النقابه في حاجه احنا لم نعلن عنها وادخلت
النقابه البيانات لم تصدرها كلها على غير
الحقيقه وكلها عاريه تماما من الصحه نحن
ندعم اي انسان مصري اي فنان مصري اي رياضي
مصري
في اي محفل ما بيشرفنا ويشرف بلدنا هل
تعتقد انه هذا اللبس صار بسبب القصه انه
اللي ذكرته او التصريح اللي صدر منكم قبل
كده انه ويجز ما جالي النقابه واجتمع معكم
لما اجتمعتم مع الفنانين الفنانين النمو
عضو مسجل في النقابه
اذا حضرتك
خبر
[موسيقى]
مصري ده موضوع ثاني خالص كل ما اثير من
جاد العبره وسائل التواصل او القنوات
[موسيقى]
اي شيء ابدا ولا اي عقوبه ولا اعلنت عقبات
اذا هيرجع لبلده سالما غانما ييجي نقابته
اي شان داخلي لينا معه اي امور داخليه
لينا معها ده بيتنا الفني وبلدنا واحنا
نتصرف مع ابننا همم داخل لقتنا كل ما اعلن
وما اثير حول اغنيه كاس العالم كلها اخبار
عاريه تمام
بين غناء في كاس العالم وبين الشان
الداخلي اللي هو عدم مثلا اخراجه لبطاقه
النقابه او ما الى ذلك اللي هي عن غناؤه
في مصر
ان شاء الله يمكن لما يرجع من السفر هو كل
الكلام اللي بيتقال اللي بيتقال ان همم ان
هذا الشاب ربنا كارمه بره في الخارج لما
يرجع باذن الله لقيته ويجيء لقته ينتمي
لها ويوقع على كافه الاقرارات والتعهدات
اللي مضى عليها كل شعبه الرياض اهلا به
طبعا ومرحب به في بلده في نقابه كشب
بمثلنا وشاب حق نجاح جماهيري كبير شرف لنا
وشرف لمصر كلها نكون اصدقاء
غير مسموح له بالغناء داخل مصر
لم ينتمي الى شعبه الراب طبقا لما قرروا
مجلس الاداره بالاجماع من الغاء كافه
التصريح اللي كانت سابقا على ان يجيء يمضي
يقرا له كل شباب جاءت وانا اعتقد ان هو
اللي شغله ممكن يكون حفلاته في الخارج
ربنا يوفقه لاول ما يجيء هنا احنا كلنا في
انتظار ده ابننا ومرحب به جدا طيب شكرا لك
على هذه المداخله وهذا التوضيح كان معنا
عبر الهاتف من القاهره مصطفى كامل نقيب
المهن الموسيقيه في مصر
[موسيقى]